over 30 million americans
will have a bill coming due in about two
months
do they pay the student loan debt or do
they keep up with their car payments
people will see their wages garnished uh
even social security checks
get garnished let's maybe think of the
movie the gremlins right
the for some folks it's never enough and
that includes these ultra progressives
the democratic socialists
they can never get enough in these bills
there's never enough money there
now you have to also remember the three
rules of the maguine the little
cute creatures from the 1980s movie they
were irresistible right but the rules
are important here rule number one
don't put them near light especially
sunlight and by sunlight in this analogy
we mean the truth because progressives
can't seem to handle it
they often get triggered rule number two
don't let the magwei get wet and don't
give them any
water to drink the water in this
metaphor is the millions of
campaign funds raised by progressives
like aoc while at the same time they cry
about the influence of money and
politics they say it's not fair
now politico recently reported aoc's
campaign largesse
and an oversight at campaign
headquarters has raised some awkward
questions
among her colleagues which brings us to
the final rule here for gremlins
no matter how much the magua cries no
matter how much it begs
never feed it after midnight because
once you do you can't stop their
appetite
and that's when these cute little
creatures turn into swamp
monsters don't forget joe biden talking
about student loan debt
has already forgiven cancelled more than
40 billion dollars worth of student loan
debt but again that's not enough for aoc
and elizabeth warren and the rest
but why well that's because progressives
seem to take their lead from people like
actress
susan sarandon she recently protested
outside of aoc's office
in the bronx to the squad and especially
aoc
who you know did make a lot of promises
that um we still have faith in you
and we would like to see if you have a
a better plan than we've been able to
see please share it
if there's a pathway that you've got
that we're not aware of please share it
because we're losing hope here that you
represent us
just off camera was a free palestine
protester who you couldn't see there
joining us to talk more about this
is the host of the reuben report dave
rubin
he's also the author of don't burn this
book thinking for yourself in an age of
reason and we've got some news on the
book front which we'll talk about in a
moment but first
dave susan sarandon she might as well be
speaker of the house
i guess john as you know
after my show tomorrow i'm going off the
grid for all of august no phone no tv no
news no guest appearances with john
bachman here on newsmax i do this
uh every august for the last five years
and part of the reason i do it is
because i have come
to absolutely hate these people
they they are all absolutely awful they
can't solve any of their own problems
and yet they want to solve
all of our problems the whole thing with
the
with the bill here it's like they don't
believe in basic
economics so whether it's 3.4 trillion
or 1.7 trillion
they don't believe in inflation they
believe you can just endlessly print
money it's very bizarre actually
that they want to endlessly tax people
because in a world where you can just
keep printing money taxation only seems
like punishment so it's really about
punishing
successful people more than having
anything to do with funding things you
want because
they just print and print and print i
mean they're all just ridiculous
that being said i am quite enjoying
watching this little rift between
cinema and the squad because it's like
yeah all right now you guys can all just
call each other racist
and uh it's a little early for me to
have popcorn in the studio but i'll just
get some popcorn and watch
i can i can smell it from here the
popcorn um
you know and what you're talking about
is this modern monetary theory that some
of these
democratic socialists believe in that
there is no limit to the amount of money
we can print
deficits and debts don't matter anymore
you know and that's what they believe
and that's why you know and again
40 billion dollars that's not a little
bit of money and joe biden has already
forgiven that amount
of student loan debt but you know you
can tell where the real
power of the democratic party is is with
the progressive left
john correct me if i'm wrong but uh when
the founders set
up the country i believe it was george
washington who said that if you are an
upper
middle class child who goes to syracuse
and racks up
65 grand in debt a year for four years
you know a couple hundred grand
for your degree in lesbian badminton
that the government should write it off
right
was that george it was maybe thomas
jefferson i'll have to check
yeah i believe it was uh to be clear i
think it was alexander hamilton
but you know i don't i don't want to
debate you on that because i want to
also talk about
joe biden's freudian slip his own words
yesterday take a listen
back in 2009 during the so-called great
recession
the president asked me to be in charge
of managing that piece then president
trump
excuse me freudian slip that was the
last president
he caused anyway that was president
obama when i was vice president
so uh you know the freudian slip is an
interesting reference here and i think
this is actually a moment of clarity
uh for president biden because what he's
saying there is uh president trump is my
daddy right basically is that what he's
saying
i mean look relative to the biden gaffes
that we see virtually every day that
one's not even
that terrible i mean just the other day
there was another one where he out of
nowhere said that he used to drive an
18-wheel truck
like that's just not true it's not true
unless unless he thinks he's working
with optimus prime on the side i mean
what is this guy talking about
uh but look the gaffes are just gonna
keep coming they we all know something's
wrong with him
everyone knows it and except for a
couple people online
and and you guys at newsmax and a few
other people mainstream refuses to talk
about it so as i've said from the
beginning with this thing the conspiracy
is the non-conspiracy right like the
fact that nobody's allowed to talk about
it
because at some point they are going to
remove him my guess if i had to take one
uh do one prediction for something that
could happen while i'm off the grid
it's that it's going to be barack obama
believe it or not it'll be barack obama
on an interview who will suddenly just
off the cuff
say something like oh maybe joe's lost a
step or something like that
and then suddenly that will be the
airlock for the mainstream media to
start asking questions
much like jon stewart when he went on
stephen colbert yes he said
that the wuhan lab leak and then
suddenly everyone started saying the
thing that we've all been saying
for a year and a half so that's how
mainstream media operates they wait
until one of their anointed sons
says something and then they all pretend
that they've known it the whole time and
that the rest of us who were just
conspiracy theorists all the time
right you know that really were
conspiracy theories and far-right
maniacs right it's not true
until someone they approve of says it's
true so all right dave you've got a
minute left
uh quite a tease uh don't burn this book
one of my favorites
of the last few years here but uh got
some news for us tell us about it
my new book is dropping tomorrow for
pre-sale it won't be out until
april but i've been working on it for
about a year now it's a follow-up to
don't burn this book i
can't john i you know i want to give you
if i wanted to give anybody
the the exclusive it would be you on the
title but we're going to announce
the title on my show tomorrow for
pre-sale i'm going to be signing
numbered copies no matter how many we
sell tomorrow
i will sign them all and then i
disappear for a month and i'm going off
the grid and it's one of the ways that i
stay sane doing what we do because
as you know you know being in the
endless news cycle uh it's tough for the
for the average person to figure out
what to consume and how not to go crazy
but it can also be tough
tough on us so i take it as a little
sabbatical every year to just kind of
refresh reset and then come
come to the news in the fall with fresh
eyes and you know what no matter what
happens in august
the world will keep going i'll be back
it'll be all right a little bit of
humility
helps everyone here and uh you know i'm
jealous intensely jealous that
you can take the whole month of august
off us news guys don't
get that luxury just a week at a time i
just came back from vacation but i'm
feeling good dave have
fun you're a pro though look you look at
you with your with your tie and you're
probably look at me i look like a shirt
have fun be safe look forward to seeing
you in about a month or so and we'll
talk then
can't wait to get the book either the
new one thanks my friend if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell